in the broadest sense an idea a comedy
about middle schoolers was something
that just seemed really interesting and
I mean but like the hook is the real
thing like they it's like something you
could do an elevator pitch up and anyone
would get it it's three kids who want to
go to a kissing part that sentence alone
yeah gets me their first christening
party it all starts when Max gets an
invitation from the cool kid of the
group I will align the group the cool
kid a school named Sauron and it's to go
to the kissing party and Max does not
know how to kiss so he needs to figure
out a way to learn how to kiss this is a
really pretty CPR doll I guess I'll go
first
what are you doing kissing her you can't
kiss someone without their permission
remember from assembly max Lucas and
Thor are kids who grew up together look
who they are still growing up they're
very young he add they are kind of
entering middle school and they're kind
of at that point in their lives were
they're kind of maybe thinking or
realizing that like the only reason
they're friends is because they were
kind of like placed together as friends
by their parents and Max is kind of
having different interests than his
other friends are and Thor and Lucas are
kind of a little more you know slower to
develop than he is in some ways just
emotionally and I think like at least in
Max's eyes they're at a bit of a
crossroads as far as like will we remain
friends throughout middle school
tomorrow even what can throw Lucas good
you're so random they're my best friends
would do everything together doesn't
meet girls at the party you know that
means drama no kissing their friendship
is pretty strong actually they're called
the beanbag boys and they do everything
together they go on adventures together
they fly drones together and do
inappropriate stuff together I've sworn
a lot in movies before but this is a
next level for sure lots of new words I
had to learn we could spy on my neighbor
shoo total nymphomaniac
she starts fires no she's a nymphomaniac
someone who has sex on land and sea they
really understood on this film
specifically that like the conceptual
element that the kids don't understand
things the way an adult would they
really like took that and expanded it
and made it the best part of the movie
they understood that like their
viewpoint was the funniest part